[Music]
okay we just got done seeing one things
just called penguins what not yet thing
life and it's a have a Disney nature
flick about the Penguins the documentary
documentary yeah and what they do now
with these new nature of documentaries
is they kind of pick an animal and
they'll make a story around them and you
know it's about a penguin who mates and
raises the family may you know and then
they go off to the sea you know but
fantastic photography yeah it was really
really beautiful yeah it's kind of it's
like watching an ancient movie but at
least there's a little story to go along
with it there's a bunch of humor
hokey ass sucking songs man I play it
yeah I was laughing the whole thing
they're playing Whitesnake you know I
just yeah it has a cover it is just you
know corniest [ __ ] but it was [ __ ]
funny
well I think it was oh of course because
I mean so this focus is on I like the
way they focused on one particular
penguin instead of like the whole I mean
you know they they focused on all of the
things that this particular colony but
they focused on one that they needed
Steve that was this was apparently his
first year traveling back to you rates
chicks so it hadn't went through the
whole like their whole year and like
finding a maid and like raising the
chicks and
and I thought I thought it was super
cute I mean then they show everything
that's happening on Antarctica predatory
Birds great white
not everybody actually call them killer
whales CEO yeah different kinds of
paying ones like emperor penguins
so you know it's kind of just a standard
nature documentary but they put a twist
on it by putting a story behind it but
some crazy songs and you know the the
purpose of these movies is that an adult
can take a kid to go see a documentary
and everybody can have a good time and
it's not dry boring and I think that a
good accomplished its mission yeah
stories he kind of shows his way along
as like as soon as it started they
showed that one little thing was just
like walking all by himself because he
kept getting lost all sense of direction
but um I was like he walks just like our
kitty cat yeah because that little
modely but the purpose of the thing is
that you can take a kid to come see a
movie and the kid loves it they're
totally entertained and it doesn't drive
you crazy you're laughing at it and
you're in you're admiring the
photography there's a lot of really cool
underwater photography with icebergs and
stuff like that you know stuff that
would be hard to get to hard to see in a
normal life I mean who goes who goes to
Antarctica
yeah very few people oh man look it's
where I've busted myself and then in the
jaw and the hole with the car oh [ __ ]
yesterday opening the door close the
door
yeah hit myself in everything I had
right there I have to say my
because my favorite scene in this movie
was when Steve was trying to because
they build little nests set of rocks
like today yeah ladies so he's like
building the nest and this is his first
time doing it because he's only five
years old and like you can see that
other penguins like around there like
checking him out like wait for him to
leave and as soon as he turns his back
they go and steal is right yeah you
could see they were just and you can see
they were just like they were trying to
play it off like they weren't stealing
they were stealing his rocks yeah yeah
wait for him to turn his back I mean
they're not jerk they're not smart but
they're not that dumb yeah they know it
all about stealing and lying and
deceiving and trying I gotta take it
goodbye and take ya there's like what I
didn't you know yeah but uh yes you know
I think the movie achieved what I was
trying to do yeah it's like you know
what I mean if you like nature
documentaries probably love those kids
would probably love it because it's got
like a funny voice over and like you
know achieve the Assam assembly kind so
it's really have you
[Music]
you
okay we just read watch us which is uh
you know it was into the horror movie it
was pretty good I think was actually
probably better on the second viewing
kind of knowing how it ended that's
exactly what I was gonna say because
here's the thing like I said before we
decided that since we have this you know
whole thing that AMC stem sale is just
like we don't really want to have to go
like force ourselves too much because I
was excited to watch that all movies and
[ __ ] like there wasn't much left this
week that was any good that we gave a
crap about so I said well why do we go
rewatch some stuff that we actually
liked and we'll see if you know how it
is on the second time and I'm actually
really excited that I got to see the
second time as I liked it so much the
first time and like you said I think
it's really good to watch it knowing
what the ending is yeah so you can kind
of pick up because it's so much richer
experience when you know what the end is
so you can like look for all the clues
yeah that first 20 minutes that the
first 20 minutes there's a setup in
there and if you really don't know how
it ends you can't really see the setup
as well I think yeah this is definitely
a movie that like gets better on re
watches and like I said the more you
because I had actually like read some
reviews of it after we watched it and I
rewatched get out and you know which
doesn't have anything to do with this
move
necessarily it's just you know the same
director and stuff so so one thing that
I really liked was like I picked up like
so much more stuff like did you see like
at the beginning of the movie like when
they're closing in on that Hands Across
America ad yeah and then there's
videotapes on the side yeah okay well
one of the ones I noticed was chud which
idea I was funny cannibalistic humanoid
underground dwellers ooh ya know but I
didn't notice the first time you know
what they had little ones to the man
with two brains
okay there's also the right in it like
twins the right stuff was there too
which is yeah strong movie yeah I'm not
sure what they're I'm not sure what and
I noticed too like that The Goonies was
there and then later on like very near
the end of the movie there is actually
kind of an oblique reference to two
Goonies where when read who was the main
characters doppelganger when she says
you know it's our time up there that is
a paraphrase from the Goonies where he
says it's our time down here because
they don't sounds like looking for the
pirate trick how'd the kid figure out
his mother's been switched people really
I don't know if he knew exactly but he's
I think he started to suspect something
was different about her when he saw her
in their neighbor's house killing that
twin sister because she was wailing on
this she was like almost animalistic
yeah and I think that that kind of made
him suspect it's like is this really my
mom anymore because she was acting like
one of the tethered so I think that like
after that happened and then I think
when during the Bigfoot during the fight
unity and did what would did yeah and
then during the fight scene I think that
he's suspected that red had taken his
mom's place right which she didn't
really but I think he suspected that
it's like oh that's she's one of them
you know what I mean so like I said I'm
not sure I thought she was yeah well she
did start out with John of them yeah you
know so like I said now and I really
liked like knowing that
it's really good to watch a second time
I mean honestly I really think I mean I
love to get out but I think I liked this
one a bit better this have had more over
camera was gory ER it was scarier I
think then you know it had creepier
moments then it has a really good score
the score is amazing I loved it the
cinematography is amazing like I said
there's like so much like symbolism and
it's like everything means something
like every single thing in the
background like I I saw like other board
games like in the closet I'm like funny
oh yeah I think the only thing I can
find wrong with it do anything I can
knock it for was the depress of having
clones trying to share one soul and how
the government somehow uses them
underground that it's but I understand
you know I think I am like it's more
symbolic yeah it's not like realistic
yes however it's not plausible but what
but what they're doing is is it's a very
original idea yeah like that I was you
never seen that look before it's you
know it's a very original idea I mean
it's not a vampire movie it's a zombie
movie it's not superheroes it's not it's
just its own movie which I like that
it's doppelgangers but you know we were
than done yeah yeah I mean and like I
said it's really kind of cool like what
you know what you it can be read like in
a lot of ways and I think that's like
the best thing about these types of yeah
I think I might be I think it might be
an evade an analogy it is yeah of
specifically I kind of read it as you
know the underclass they're just like us
but you know they don't have the same
you know they've crappy stuff when we
have good stuff and probably just
they're like invisible to us and you
know stuff like that and they're kind of
coming back to get what they feel like
they deserve and all this other kind of
yeah but you know and like I said that's
why he used the hands across America
yeah I cannot repeat because that was
like yeah there's no join hands like
homeless there's definitely a
revolutionary theme a theme of uprising
in it yeah yeah but yeah it's pretty
good flick but yeah honestly seeing it
again I think it's probably a
masterpiece and I like it a little bit
better than get out like I really like
to get out but I think this is actually
a better raver yeah now we're gonna be
see Shazam yeah that's the next one
we're gonna see I like it I like to see
this dance up yeah
you
okay just got dumb the second viewing of
Shazam
and I have to say that I thought it
stood up to second viewing I thought it
was good I think you know I mean I was
uh I was able to pick up a couple couple
things that I hadn't noticed before
especially in that last fight so much
stuff happens the first time you see and
it kind of overwhelms you you don't it
just kind of goes right through you you
don't really you know I mean you see it
but you don't really broke to what
happened in terms of like how much the
the kids do once they transform yeah
they did a lot of stuff yeah you know
and you really remember them doing that
much but they did they were they were
distracting all those monsters while I
did do some research after the first
viewing to go back and see
Shazam you know I grew up watching the
television version of it and I didn't
know that there was a bunch of animated
versions I think was like three or four
little animated movies that had Yash's
am in them you know I think he appears
in like Justice League animated stuff
and the movie is true to the tone he is
kind of a comedic character in the
animated version so yeah this is it
manatee they captured that character and
I think it was kind of cool that they
took not even a b-list maybe like a C or
a d-list DC character that nobody's
really interested in it took that and
actually made it a make a kick-ass movie
out of it that I'd like to see the yeah
yeah that's what I really liked about
this movie and honestly and I think I
said this before we you know we saw
that's the second time as well it's like
what I like a movie the first time a lot
of times I like to see it the second
time because what you already know
what's gonna happen you know and you
know what the story is you can like look
out for little details and stuff and so
I think this time I liked it a lot
better the second time around like the
humor still funny
you could pick up so much more like
stuff going on in the background like
all the other characters and just you
know all this little stuff I'm like all
these little like off you know little
lines and stuff that I didn't really pay
attention to the first time also I have
to say that the first time we saw this
we saw the first after credit little
scene yeah there's another one at the
very very very very very very end like
after all the long boil it's only like
10 seconds long but it was but the movie
is kicking ass at the box office that
didn't cost much to make it's doing very
well they think it'll at least make 400
million they're already gonna make a
sequel and the rock will be in the
sequel he had to do with the with the
production of this movie yeah and after
like 2 or 3 days I think but I think
after the third or fourth day he came
out on on Instagram saying that you know
hey we're gonna make another movie I'm
glad you guys like it I'm gonna be in
the second he's gonna play black out of
a cat a man yeah which is a character
from Shazam but I have to say like I
said and I might have said this first
time to you but it's like reinforced the
second time best thing about this
Zachary Levi the guy that play Shazam
and also all the kid actors of this
fantastic
yeah and I especially loved the kid that
plays Freddie you know the the little
bits his little sidekick or whatever
that kid is awesome yeah hilarious and
also the little girl with Darla I just
like that they took a glutton of goofy
premise and superheroes are goofy
premise and they go like this shit's
goofy and they get make and they [ __ ]
con just power through it to make until
it becomes cool and like I said it's
like fun for them for the whole yeah
it's fun and like I said I think I saw
the first one it's just it has so much
heart it's like yes we movie like it
really care about all these little kids
and about this character and if you want
him to you know you want him to succeed
you have been stopped you know to be a
hero and stuff like that and it did I
really really liked that they were able
to pull that off and have it still be
super funny
yes um entertaining for me a lot of
these superhero movies
if the tone is really super serious and
the costumes - in the costumes of the
wood looking the way they do and just it
just comes off looking [ __ ] nerdy to
me but if if you have fun with it like
the way this movie does and kind of the
way Aquaman - yeah then it just kind of
become it comes it goes into the nerd
realm and then it comes back around
getting around and catches like yeah
okay so you know you know I like that
tone and I like I see the Joker I don't
know how I think the Joker is gonna have
a different tone but it's gonna be also
decent but I have high hopes that that's
gonna be exactly what they intended to
be which is I think of disturbing I
think that's going to be a disturbing
yeah I think that's gonna be a
disturbing movie I'd like to see it by
the way we're doing this out in the car
because tonight is the opening night of
Avengers game [ __ ] impact in the parking
lot I mean we've been here all day yes I
like it too but so we have a spot but
there is no there is no parking I went
out on civilian people I went out a lot
I went out a lobby to go to the men's
room and saw a full-grown gay man in
[ __ ] [ __ ] Spiderman PJ's with his
mom his mom's with it - I just saw a
little kid and he an Iron Man mask and a
Captain America spider-man PJs on red
sneakers baseball cap on sideways and
like a big gulp and he's standing out
there with his mom Wow
I got scared right I got scared I gotta
go
you